i told you to move from over here hey
boy you told me what told you that you
had to move man i didn't know no you
can't you can't handle over here you're
not panhandling but when i saw you you
were and you're still i'm not you're
still here in the middle
okay
sign or anything well you're dead when i
saw you in there
no you didn't i haven't had it i've
never had a sign i only had a sign for
asking people for money brother i'm not
asking anybody for money you were no i'm
not
you cannot find anything oh okay okay
listen
the fact still remains
you cannot stand here in the middle of
the intercept in the middle of this
intersection right here okay where's the
law that says that i can't stand oh
there there are many laws no no
well all right now you're now i can i
can literally i can literally
i didn't ask her for it you cannot stand
in the middle of this area okay
you need to go where's the statue that
says that i cannot okay i'll show you
i'll show you but as of right now if you
don't move right now i'm gonna take you
to jail okay
i'm gonna tell you
i'm
you cannot stand in the middle of this
intersection but there's no law that
says i can't stand here they're not
asking for this is this is not a
sidewalk sir this is not a sidewalk this
is a this is a
this is a median for beer vehicular
traffic you are you are out you you
listen
you are out in the road i'm telling you
right now okay well if you can show me
this okay i cannot i'm right there i'm
letting you wrong right now this is not
a sidewalk this is the road
you are this is the road you cannot be
out in the road you need to be out on
the sidewalk you cannot stay in here you
cannot set up camp here you have been
here sometime since the last time i told
you to move off of there
i if you want me to show you a statue
cool but i'm going to show you a statue
taking you to jail you can't take me to
the vote just for standing here man
are you going to see us i don't have to
show you a statue you can look that up
on your own you can go to the police
department if you feel like your rights
are being violated but you are on a road
okay are you a veteran
oh yes i'm a veteran
you're a veteran i know yes you should
be ashamed of yourself okay get off of
the sidewalk i'm gonna also need your
audi
collect your things and i'm also need
your audi
next time i see you out here brother
i'm going to either watch it
i'm either right yet i'm either write
you a ticket no
i'm either write you a ticket or you're
going to go to jail i'm just letting you
know it's going to happen
because you're here panhandling that's
what you're doing that bothers me man
well you need to move off to the side
brother
oh
all right there it's cool
if you come over here
what i'm telling you is that
whether you call a panhandle or not
that's what i'll call it when i saw you
up here you were waving at people
that's not okay
okay
i'm not let me talk
there are people rolling by you're
taking money from them as they you are
taking money for them from them
as they
are rolling down their windows it
appears that you're panhandling second
of all this is not a this right here
this is gaster mall drive right this is
a legal intersection right here okay so
this is the intersection this is the
road all right the side of the sidewalk
is where you can be at if you're just
going to weigh the people there and not
panhandle that's fine but when you're
not asking okay okay that's fine you you
saw for yourself i was standing there
talking to you and a lady came up and
gave me dog food for her and handed me
ten dollars okay now did you see me ask
for it no you didn't exactly
ask me okay but like i listen i can
still write you if you want me to write
you i can i'm telling you i told you to
move over here from over off of here
initially this is a public road you
cannot be in the middle of the public
world standing on the median okay i
don't have to show you a statue you can
look that up yourself i'm telling you
that is the law right now
you can look that up on north carolina
general statutes if i if you are if you
are in the road that is the road
that is the rule you are legally allowed
to be on the sidewalk but this is for
vehicular traffic you cannot be out in
the middle of the road
you cannot be out in the middle of the
road you cannot set up camp in the
middle of the road you cannot do that
okay i don't want you to be in the grass
and i could be on the sidewalk yup all
right however
i don't care if no other officer pulls
you over for it i don't care if another
ulcer doesn't detain you for it i'm not
other officers i have discretion i can
tell you right there that has violated
north carolina general statute if you
want to know the statute i don't have to
show it to you when i arrest somebody
for domestic violence
public servant you work for me so you're
supposed to when i ask you something
you're supposed to take care of it and
be like okay it's the statute you're
okay okay okay
there is no there is no law that says
that i'm also a disabled veteran and i
know how the va works okay
so you don't have to just say what
you're doing so you don't necessarily
know man
it's not condescending when i tell you
to move off of a public roadway you move
off of a public roadway okay that is how
that works there is nothing that says i
have to literally show you the statue
i'm telling you it is against north
carolina general statutes if i see you
out here again okay then we're going to
handle that in a more legal way okay
well you're going to see me bro i look
here if i if i see you i can't take me
to jail just for seeing me bro i can no
i'm saying if you are out in the middle
of the roadway again you cannot be out
in the middle of the roadway
okay but i can cross right there can i
you can cross it but if i see you
standing if i see you
setting up camp right there just like as
you were because i left and i came back
30 minutes later and you were in the
same spot yeah and i moved all my stuff
i took all my stuff and then you came
and then you went back to the same spot
okay
that's how that is you cannot be there
okay
do you get it
yeah i understand but i appreciate it
sir you have a better day
[Music]
so
right now i believe we're starting at
like 48
46 or 48.
yeah yeah like he's a bonus for like if
you're intermediate
uh as a bonus if uh
are you already a police officer
i was a professor
yeah yeah you you get a lot i mean i do
know you get a bonus for uh
having a bachelor's degree though okay
in the two-year and things like that all
right all right
if you are a disabled veteran brother i
am
wow
about that i i don't believe you're
alone but what i'm saying is
that they're well
but there's only so much that the va
does for you how about how about housing
they don't help you with housing at all
uh
i just got in touch with the people that
do that they put me in a hotel for like
three days and then once they realize
that i received disability they put me
out because i don't qualify since i
actually have rating is your rating high
enough to i'm guessing it's not high
enough because it's not high enough to
support myself have you
have you looked into um
i'm doing all that man like trust me i'm
going through listen man we receive
direction that that we are not supposed
to have people i don't care if you're on
the sidewalk i really don't yeah we
receive direction that we are not
supposed to have people like and medians
like at the intersections of those
of of the highway the rants okay
i'm doing what i'm what i'm told to do
okay if you're not paying handling phone
i didn't write your panhandling i agree
with you she just gave you money i get
it but you cannot be in the middle
that's all i'm saying man that's all i'm
saying however when it goes for um when
it goes to just being in the middle and
things like that if also ask you to move
and i get it that no officer does yeah
but during that i'm up and smiling
i do well i mean we're not even supposed
to do that but i mean that's against
policy however day shift i know for
example day chef is very busy day shift
comes in just up until i get here
they bring me dog food too there's
several guys that bring that food and
water dog food and water that's fine
because it's not money okay the statute
says money solicit money okay
but i mean if it's not that then that's
fine honestly
i'm only concerned with you being in the
middle of the
middle of the median or the intersection
you you just can't do that because this
is still considered a public rule this
is still considered guessing mall drive
even though it looks like a private
vehicular area it's not
all right but as far as the va
have you
do they have anything in charlotte that
has like homeless housing or anything
like that
they're i'm in contact with a group of
people that does stuff like that right
now and i'm just waiting to hear back
from them to try and assist me all right
i mean what about your
so you have a rating and now like i said
there's none of my business but if
you're over a certain percentage there
are things that you can do such as uh
vocational rehab
it's like it's like i'm declared
unemployable
so you're 100 i'm guessing uh close to
it okay
so are you total and permanent or
so have you looked at like people who
hire vets such as we hire vats or
anything like that
um
i'm not
like i've done that before but
like being unemployable like the va gave
me a pension because i'm unemployable
due to my ptsd my ptsd is so severe
that i can't function without a service
dog okay so
you know i can't
go and
work even if i wanted to
you know what i'm saying like
i have uh acute psychosis and
uh it causes me to have flashbacks and
things that's what she's for
and
you know that's what what years were you
on uh well what years were you when oh
well i joined o2 right after 9 11.
i graduated high school 02
uh joined three months later june 22nd
2002 and i shipped overseas
so
so there's nothing else that you there's
nothing else that you can do
than in the other thing be out here yeah
i'm really not man except for getting
help with them and
uh that's it man i'm i'm doing
what i got to do and it's out of
necessity man
[Music]
all right man listen um
i just know that you can't be in the
road i don't care if you're on the
sidewalk man do what you got to do to
live man uh
and i i really do wish you the best of
luck thank you we see the best of luck i
apologize that
that your country has underserved you
um i honestly don't know your entire
situation so i can't really speak on it
right um i know my situation i mean i
know what i do through the va yeah um
yeah i mean
and i appreciate all your service man
i'm sorry for the things that you've
been through as well i mean it's fine
man it is what it is well i want you to
bust a lot man good luck have a good
night
[Applause]
i just saw you take money from that car
yeah you saw me take money but you
didn't see me asking all right let me
get your id okay
you can't ask for my id yes i give you
money okay get your dog okay
yes i can it's called panhandling but
it's not panhandling if i didn't ask for
it is it
id you can give me your id or you go to
jail which one you wanted what's the id
for that because i'm about to write you
a citation
for what for panhandling that's not
panhandling
yes it is no it's not if you come up to
me and give me money you walked out to
the car because they stopped did you see
them stop give me you saw the whole
situation give me your id or you're
going to jail for rdo which is resist
delay of struck
okay you're going to write a disabled
veteran that's living in the woods a
ticket yes because i asked you not to do
it and i didn't do it you're sitting
there watching i'm packing my stuff up i
sit there and watch you watch me walk up
the sidewalk
i'm out with that that subject like you
literally watch me walk up the sidewalk
give me your id
you're gonna write me a ticket yes
i'm all dry
yes
i didn't commit a crime
you buy you violate a city
no i didn't there's no city ordinance
that says somebody can't give me money
and you obstructed traffic no i didn't
they did they did they instructed you to
put the one in the car give me your id
sir i'm not giving you my id because i
didn't break this channel
no channel but i probably need a
sergeant out here
he's refusing to give me his id
now you see we got a sergeant and
multiple units on their way out here and
i can almost guarantee you is
it's not going to go the way you want it
to go i want to talk to a supervisor
he's on his way out here
he's on his way out here
[Music]
yeah yeah so now he's refusing to give
me his id because i'm going to write him
for violating the city
because you're first of all i mean it
it can be inferred okay because that's
the way the law works right things can
be inferred so if it appears that you're
violating the ordinance that's how that
works right but if so
let me tell you
we're
and you were you were walking down like
this because i sit there and observe you
and that lady is a witness down there
yeah and i walked up
[Laughter]
[Music]
was scared okay i'm telling you right
now you don't give me you're going to
jail i'm calling animal control on your
dog
dude i didn't commit this crime
but you're also in the media and after
i've told you not to be here before
have i not said that and that's why i
was vacant because she asked me to leave
and i was literally i also had asked you
not to take money for money okay that's
right i'm taking this to draw you can't
you can't it's going to go to trial
anyway you don't even have to ask what's
that i would not waste the time
okay
i pay my taxes too
there you go
well we you're stayed out there not your
vehicle yeah
it's not bad i need your state id not
your va i think i'm at you one more time
you're not even balancing your trade
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not doing anything
[Applause]
oh
oh
why are you doing this
[Applause]
it bent my foot and i knew
relax and give me your hands
why are you doing this i haven't done
anything
cooperating
don't hit him
somebody help me record it
please help me why are y'all doing this
to me
guys y'all
why are y'all doing this to
[Music]
did you see the dog bite his foot dude
he tased my dog of course
like seriously why are y'all doing this
right now but we have to do our job
okay here's the thing y'all didn't see
the whole story so just back you didn't
either
oh
[Music]
somebody please help me they're trying
to kidnap me
i don't know what they do with sunshine
where is my dog
sunshine ray
i need my dogs he's my medical device
where is my dog
where is my dog
where is my dog
where's my dog
where's my dog now what are you gonna do
with my dog
hold on to him where is my dog
good yeah
all right please crank my hand up why
are you doing this to me
sir we politely asked you for your idea
you always give them my id it's on your
webcam
i was literally handing you my idea they
tackled me
so i drove off to speak with a witness
down there are you good
i'll taste good
my dog is running away and he shot her
while she was running away i didn't
shoot her
yes he did he tasted her for no reason
my dog's never hurt anybody and neither
am i
i'm just smiling waving people
sorry i don't know where my dog is hey
man where's my dog let me explain it to
you okay listen
whose car is that hey let's pop them in
your car
i don't know they won't tell me where
sunshine is
where is sunshine
where's my dog man i don't know his dog
ah she's advocating for him no don't cut
my backpack man this is mine
okay
[Applause]
i can tell my hand ain't completely
healed
i really like my dog man
oh
that's the one he was trying to give and
taylor asked him for
a uh
his real id and he refused
never healed when i came back
[Music]
no it was coming up behind me yeah
okay
what's the is the call was him
panhandling oh and so i spoke to him and
then i went off to speak to the witness
who flagged me for it have you told him
today get off the meeting i told i told
him a few days ago okay and it's on
camera i can find it it was one other
shit but you've been
so as i was speaking to the witness i'm
looking back at him and he walks from
there down to here with his hands like
this and then goes and gets money from
okay
a car
now the lady that was
another lady over here is that the lady
that wanted to talk to me
no he wanted a sergeant oh he did okay
they didn't see it all they didn't see
anything all they saw was
the aftermath for me because i heard him
say the dog bit me and then i could feel
the dog come in between my legs uh i did
not want the dog to bite my partner
while we're trying to detain the man and
we don't know what he has before
that's that's that's that yeah
and you've seen the dog go which one
it ran down this way
all right
let me get his insulin
oh
hey how's it going i'm doing all right
sir oh just out with him i told him he
couldn't be on the median yeah that's
why i was packing my stuff up walk out
to a car to get money yeah i saw him at
the circle k the other day uh with the
car
yeah so now he's refusing to give me his
id because i'm going to write him
she's trying to rank me a ticket because
i was walking up this packing up she
told me to pack up and i was literally
listening and somebody stopped gave me
money you saw it yesterday he saw it too
people give me money without me asking i
don't know because because because
you're first of all i mean it
it can be inferred okay because that's
the way the law works right things can
be inferred so if it appears that you're
violating the ordinance that's how that
works right but if so if you're so so so
let me tell you
because you're not a lawyer you can get
one but i can tell you how the law works
you're in the median right
you're waving at people in the median
after after i've told you you're down
like this yes
and that lady is a witness down there
yeah and i walked up but listen
like you told me i just want you to know
you can go to jail for this ordinance if
you if you can listen if you can if you
continue to argue with officers you're
going to go to jail
and we're going to work this time
you cannot be here that's fine i told
her i was like
you asking for money because yeah
dude i didn't commit this crime
but you're also in the media and after
i've told you not to be here before
have i not said that and that's why i
was vacating because she asked me to
leave and i was literally walking up
here i didn't ask anybody for money okay
that's right i'm taking this to trial
you can't that's fine you can it's gonna
go to trial anyway you don't even have
to oh it's going to try not you're
wasting taxpayer dollars okay well i pay
my taxes too
there you go
no we your state id not your vehicle
this isn't valid it's not valid i need
your state id not your va id i'm going
to ask you one more time you're not even
valid give me your state
[Applause]
call your dog off call your dog off call
your dog off call your dog off
call your dog off start call your dog
off
call your dog off he just bet me
he bet me call your dog off to charlie
call your dog
call your dog
pull your dog
call your dog
we need we need you
charlie 10 city we need more units we
need more units
[Applause]
turn
it bit my foot and i knew i was going to
bite you so
about the dog
10-4 it didn't break my boob but it bit
my food
help me
what do you do
and give me your hands
why are you doing this i haven't done
anything
cooperating
sir
he's gone
but when we are out here trying to get
something from him and it won't happen
i have to do what i have to do the dog
bit me okay no i did it because you shot
him with a taser
to you
[Applause]
okay can y'all just back up please did
you see the dog bite his foot dude he
tased my dog of course
like seriously why are y'all doing this
okay but we have to do our job
we have to do our job y'all didn't see
the whole source and just thought you
please help me somebody record them
thank you i need your information
somebody please tell me they're trying
to kidnap me
did he see the dog bite i don't know
what they do with sunshine
where is my dog
ray
i need my dog she's my medical device
where's my dog
where's my dog
where's my dog
where is my dog
where is my dog what are you gonna do
with my dog
where is my dog
we're trying to detain the owner of
course the dog's gonna and i asked him
to call this dog off the dog got on the
dog got on the hood of the car and the
dog began barking the dog and me the dog
initially barked and bit my boot but it
didn't break my boob i don't i didn't
want i did not want this dog to bite my
partner you understand
okay we asked for his id he refused us
to give us his id
i'm not sure she's mad because he's here
all the time and they don't like they
don't like the fact that we had to do
what we had to do
please help me i'll taste good
yeah it didn't break but everybody's out
everybody's out here
his dog initially bit me no you didn't
break my dog
while she was running away i didn't
shoot her i teased him yes he did he
tasted it
so he was out here we've been we told
him
i'm just going to give you a background
on the whole story we told i came out
here last week right he was in the
median
i told him a little move from the medium
because he was begging for money he says
i'm just waving i'm not doing anything i
was like okay well you at least you have
to get off the median okay you can't be
in the median
he's like
basically he's like well i can be on the
sidewalk he went over to the sidewalk i
let that be
okay today brooks was out here with him
she watched them she saw him take money
from people getting money from people
you can articulate that is
celeste the money because he's standing
in the median after i told him last week
not to do the same thing okay uh i guess
he refused to give brooks his id
he refused to give brooks's id so he
gave us his va id and i said no not your
va id i need your
your license okay
i understand the va id doesn't have
certain information on it i'm also
i'm also i'm also a veteran myself i get
it okay
so um
he he's he starts getting angry and now
he's like this one is not violent this
one is not violent take my va idea i was
like no sir i need your state id that
you have
and i go and
he starts hollering and keeps like
shoving in my face saying this is not
violent and i try to get it from him he
doesn't give it to me
his north carolina because we're trying
to identify him so i go to put him in
handcuffs he starts resisting saying
help help scream and help his dog
starts looking worried and whatnot he
runs over he runs over to my foot and he
nips it like he like he nips at my foot
doesn't net but he actually bites my
boot but it doesn't break my boob at
that point i'm telling him the call off
is gone okay
yeah at that point yeah that's exactly
where it was i told him to call off his
dog the dog jumps up on the hood and i'm
thinking it's going to bite brooks at
this point as we're doing this because
the dog is obviously worried
it's tron it's going to try to protect
his owner it already bit me okay so at
this point once the dog looked like us
about to get across the brooks i tased
it
because that was the logical thing to do
somehow
it ran away that's a logical thing to do
instead of shooting the dog
you get what i'm saying
and so i can protect my partner because
i'm not about to let my partner get
bit by a dog it's a german shopper
how big is it
oh it's about this big
and it's a very well trained dog
i asked him multiple times to call his
dog off i was like sir call your dog off
call your dog yeah after it bit me i
said call your dog off call your dog off
i did not want it to bite brooks because
we because we were like
was coming up behind me yeah came up
this can all be seen on camera
thank you
hey here's his id
we're all from there that's the idea he
tried to give us and i told him i was
like hey can i get your state id and he
kept
it
done anything else
uh he's in the back everyone open it up
did you ever get a is that okay perfect
this is the one
he's just being very argumentative
what's the call the call was him
panhandling and so i spoke to him and
then i went off to speak to the
witnesses
have you told him today get off the
media i told him a few days ago okay and
it's on camera i can find it it was on
the other ship but you've been you've
told him i've told him before to get off
the media speaking to the witness i'm
looking back at him and he walks from
there down to here with his hands like
this and then goes and gets money from
okay
a car
now the lady that was
another lady is that the lady that
wanted something
for us no he wanted a sergeant oh he did
okay
she's a witness to all the businesses
i've seen
it all they didn't see anything all they
saw was
the aftermath of me tasting the dog and
everybody the dog bit me and then i
could feel the dog come in between my
yeah
i did not want the dog to bite my
partner while we're trying to detain a
man and we don't know what he has on
them of course that's that's that yeah
this guy stands out here all the time
like seriously why are you doing this
okay but we have to do our job with
get on the sidewalk
back up
[Music]
[Music]
where's my
um
i need your help
please
[Music]
well they're mad because the dog got
tased or something i don't know
i'm not really 100 what's going on right
now
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know they won't tell me where
sunshine is
just try to be calm just go out
listen i can't put you in the back of my
car in the backpack okay we don't know
what you got in it all right
calm down oh calm no that does not calm
us down
are you any needles
no crime
where's my dog
[Music]
where is my dog
[Music]
man this is so messed up
[Music]
this is so crazy man
look at the whole squad out here though
well it's not because of you please
department sorry listen listen to me
it's not because of you it's because of
the radio traffic that we heard we
didn't know what was going on
okay
so what i didn't want to fall off there
by looking out here
is
um
i need my dog i need my dog man that's
my medical advice man
there's a service on me that's my dog i
gotta know where my dog is please help
me
[Music]
they're lying on them
um
and
go go
hey we got your dog man
tj maxx they've got her
tj mac yep
hey taylor you want to get your car out
of the road
hey somebody can come and pick up my
dogs he doesn't need to go to the
channel
officer okay
um
all right forward to charlie 40 go to
four
all right well if you find her he said
he's got somebody that can come and get
her instead of calling animal control
uh
oh
uh
[Music]
hey ho ho ho ho
are you here for us
he said don't clean that dog
i'm about to talk would you
let me handle it yes sir
it says that somebody can come and get
the dog
um
sergeant somebody i don't know if i ran
into tj maxx or what
did
they just keep
charging
[Music]
i can yeah
i can yeah
hey brooks
will you at least take his bag store in
the deck
um
like a civilian yeah some random person
took her to the animal hospital yeah
don't have it
i think
he asked
are you taking home
yeah i got you
i'll let him give a statement and then
so apparently a concerned citizen took
the dog
no idea
[Music]
um do you need one of us to go with you
huh
what's your phone number what's your
fault
i'm gonna be smiling
is that we've already told you is that
the urgent care in belmont
yeah a concerned citizen took it
i just let my dog go with somebody
we can't help
we didn't let it go
somebody picked it up and took it
we're taking care of your dog
[Music]
am i good to go and transport him
do anything else from him i'm going to
transport his id
72 one time white male transport
transformed for back to 30.
from what i understand yes
or whatever
oh
hello
did you hear all that
yeah let me uh let me get this guy to
the gym and i'll call you back
[Music]
so
right
okay
oh
okay
need to be that normal
so
okay
2 47.
myself i'm back for 30 or 23 county
me too
all right man you're gonna step out for
me
and my costs are messed up
wow
second okay
[Music]
right here
[Music]
this time
do you feel comfortable with the same
console
please just favorite the better one
wrong i can't take
thank you
hey stop don't move
hey
is there a rest i need them in here
is their arrest
huh
[Music]
h u r e r
j o s h u a r o h r e r
seizures mental health issues mental
health
mental health
ptsd depression uh
paranoid disorder
all right anxiety depression
paranoid
ptsd
yeah i got that one first
i'll apologize
oh i think they're broke
just put them
thank you
sound good
i'll
focus
breathe
this is
[Music]
way
what type of dog was it a large dog
it's like um
like a medium sized maybe like a mixture
or something like that but they're out
here all the time the dog is you can
come up with
bobby was startled
[Applause]
he refused us to give us his idea
you've been perfectly polite cooperative
she was starting to see that
i just know this gentleman
my dog is running away and he shot her
while she was running away
yes he did he tased her for no reason my
dog never hurt anybody
so he was out here
probably animal foreign because if he's
old
no you don't throw me down i mean i'm
just trying to be straight with you but
you're more than like a dog i'm a
disabled veteran with a service dog
she was saying that he took off that way
tell it looks like i'm in the face
um
and i was given my ideas on your webcam
i
[Music]
where's my
and they don't like they don't like the
fact that we have to go
i'm just gonna
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where is
sunshine
where's my dog man
where's your dog walk over here yeah
what did y'all do with my dog
why are you treating me like that man do
you all see this
no don't cut my backpack man this is
mine
is that coming off yeah
okay
no crime
where's my dog man
where's my dogs
[Music]
just with longer facial hair
yeah
yeah i think that's you know okay
yep
please help me
why are you doing this to me
and i was giving my ideas on your webcam
i was literally hanging in my id and
they tackled me
man i need your information i need your
help
what's your phone number
running away
i just smile and waving people
i don't know who my dog is
[Applause]
i'm a disabled veteran with a service
dog i want to put him in a car and we'll
get him in the parking lot we got this
cars
i don't know they won't tell me where
sunshine is
where is sunshine
where's my dog man
where's
you don't see how they're shoving me
around
what's she saying hello
ah she's advocating for him in the video
backpack man this is mine
that's my dog
[Music]
yeah
i think they're getting uh 52 to come
out to look at taylor's tell them about
your hand
um
[Music]
i don't know if they need it or not
there's a restriction 19 vac pointed for
hello
[Music]
[Music]
everybody's out
his dog initially bit me no you chased
my dog my dog was running away and he
shot her while she was running away i
didn't shoot her yes he didn't taste her
nose
so he was out here we've been we told
him
i'm just going to give you a background
on the whole story all right we told i
came out here last week
right he was in the median
i told him to remove from the medium
because he was begging for money he says
i'm just waving i'm not doing anything i
was like okay well at least you have to
get off the median okay you can't be in
the media
he's like
basically he's like well i can be on the
sidewalk he went over to the sidewalk i
let that day okay today brooks was out
here with him she watched them she saw
him take money from people
getting money from people you can
articulate that as
solicited money because he's standing in
the media and after i told him last week
not to do the same thing
i guess he refused to give brooks's idea
he refused to give brooks's id so he
gave us his va id and i said no not your
va id i need your
your license okay
i understand that va id doesn't have
certain information on it i'm also
i'm also i'm also a veteran myself i get
it okay
so um
he he's he starts getting angry and
whatnot he's like this one is not
violent this one is not violent take my
va id i was like no sir i need your
state id that you have
and i go and
he starts hollering and keeps like
shoving in my face saying this is not
violent and i try to get it from him he
doesn't give it to me
his north carolina because we're trying
to identify him
so i go to put him in handcuffs he
starts resisting saying help help scream
and help his dog starts looking worried
and whatnot he runs over it he runs over
to my foot and he nips it like he like
he lifts up my foot doesn't net but he
actually bites my boot but it doesn't
break my boob at that point i'm telling
him to call off his dog okay
right right there yeah at that point
yeah that's exactly where it was i told
him to call off his dog the dog jumps up
on the hood and i'm thinking it's gonna
bite brooks at this point as we're doing
this because the dog is obviously
worried it's tron it's going to try to
protect his owner it already bit me okay
so at this point once the dog looked
like he was about to get close to brooks
i tased it
because that was the logical thing to do
so
it ran away that's a lot of cool thing
to do instead of shooting the dog
you get what i'm saying
and so i can protect my partner because
i'm not about to let my partner get
pulled bit by a dog the german trapper
how big was it
oh it's about this big
and it's a very well trained dog
i asked him multiple times to call his
dog off i was like sir call your dog off
call your dog
yeah after i bit me i said call your dog
off call your dog off i did not want it
to bite brooks because we
this can all be seen on camera
[Music]
uh he's in the backyard did y'all ever
get a is that okay perfect
this is the one he did not want to get
him
he was just being very
argumentative
what's the call the call was him
and so i spoke to him and then i went
off to speak to the witness and you've
already have you told him today get off
the media i told i told him a few days
ago okay and it's on camera i can find
it it was on the other ship but you've
been you've told him i've told him
before
i was speaking to the witness i'm
looking back at him and he walks from
there down to here with his hands like
this and then goes and gets money from
okay
a car
now the lady that was
the other lady is that the lady that
wanted to talk to
us no he wanted a sergeant oh he did
okay
she's a witness to all of us
see i've seen her see it all they did
they didn't see anything all they saw
was
the aftermath of me tasting the dog
everybody the dog
i did not want the dog to bite my
partner while we're trying to detain the
man and we don't know what he has on
them of course
that's that's that's that yeah
and you seen the dog go which way
it ran down this way somewhere
okay
all right
let me get his info and then
yeah i mean we're good all right yeah
but
he's good ems i'm good but uh
we're good
yeah you got something you need to talk
to me about i just think that's what all
these police for this one guy that's a
little bit ridiculous for me for this
one guy that's attacking officers and
having his dogs bite officers yes sir
that's why we're all here
because an officer got hurt yes
absolutely we're all coming out here to
make sure that our officers are okay
absolutely
okay perfect thank you thank
[Applause]
and
you
disabled veteran with a service dog
in a car
whose car is
this like why are you doing this to me
right now pop them in your car
i don't know they won't tell me where
sunshine is
where is sunshine
where's my dog
all right
calm down
you can put all this stuff in here
just put it in there
he's the last thing we need
okay
is
i told him a few days ago okay and it's
on camera i can find it
i'm looking back at him
oh
it ran down this way somewhere
[Music]
oh
please help me i'm a disabled fan they
just attacked me for no reason i was
literally
rolling up my dog's bed
did they give you did they give you
commands did they give you orders to
follow sir yes and i did i gave him my
id and when i reached out to give it to
him he grabbed my arm and said you're
under arrest your v your va id or your
actual state id
he asked for my id and i pulled out my
pa id because that's the only valid id i
have my state id is not valid it's out
of date what kind of dog you have sir
she's a service dog she's a belgian
malinois she's my medical device she's
prescribed by the veterans hospital
i'm a disabled vet and i'm service
connected right and i have mental health
i didn't do anything wrong i didn't
resist or anything i was hitting him
what's your phone number sir what's your
phone number three three six
seven seven two
zero zero three seven you can't separate
me from my service dog they're they're
trying to locate it sir
that's it we've already told you that
the urgents here in belmont
we're gonna let it go
somebody picked it up
my friends
[Music]
[Music]
don't say nothing
hello can i speak to dave down
what
that's
the number that they gave me this is
officer brooks to contact dave
this is not green
okay anyone at this number want to speak
to officer brooks
no
okay so all right thank you it's a great
call i know that's why they started
sending me about to get my number oh
that came around twice
uh
this bag had me about ready to test
somebody out
oh
hello can i speak today
this is officer brooks with the gasoline
city police department
it's ma'am
what's that it's ma'am
oh yes ma'am i'm sorry
you wanted someone to give you a call
yes
yes i'm
trying to find out what
i've been working with joshua for like
the last seven months get him off the
street we finally got his
va paperwork in and everything and i'm
trying to find out like
what the charges are if you want to get
out
um well we're still doing the paperwork
we have not went in front of the master
yet right now his charges he's been
charged with a general statute of um
soliciting
on a highway or street and then he's
also charged with the city ordinance of
solicitation
uh because he flagged down cars and
asked for money and then he's been
charged twice um with rdo which is
resist the lay-up shrub
okay
um
do you know what time it's gonna go
before the magistrate um here in the
next couple of minutes since i get off
the phone with you
[Music]
the state a north carolina as a veteran
service officer
um
we just got his va paperwork in so we
can
look at getting him into this treatment
program
tim suggested
that one of his options will go to
um
let me pull it up on my phone are you
are you talking about like a rehab
facility
[Music]
[Music]
dog
it is cold
it's a veterans treatment court
uh we're trying to get them help with
this ptsd
and they have one in
uh
that
we can try and get him into
if the magistrate will let us do that
um it's up to the master what kind of
bond he has um but he does have charges
pending and he has charges pending for
resisting an officer
and the same thing that we just
encountered with him
so i can't tell you what the bond is
going to be it's completely up to the
master
all right
[Music]
no sir when it goes to court you can
but not
not right now if the master
i can give him your number and he can
use the phone out here and if he chooses
to call you it's up to him
okay
okay i appreciate that all right you're
welcome
thank you
no first of all
he's a vso for who that just did not
sound legitimate at all i'm gonna hold
you
guys
you ready
there there'll be like you know the
footage out so the public could see as
well so
you know look do we know what's going on
too
no ma'am
why not well you're not directly
involved in the case so
no but we had to see it and we know the
guy and we're very involved
with him i understand that but unless
you're his attorney and you're going to
subpoena the video
on behalf of being his attorney then no
ma'am okay so what about when they have
like footage out when officers
do things and they show it on the news
how does that come out that comes after
the whole investigation is done and the
case is closed
so maybe after everything comes out we
can see the footage
that's only if his attorney
subpoenas it to be put out to the public
okay and um
don't you think they should have
probably like if the dog was being
aggressive they shouldn't let it get
away then and okay i understand that and
you're speaking with the officer that
was directly involved the arresting
officer
well that's good
that dog became aggressive that dog
became aggressive once we put hands on
the owner
that i don't understand why why was he
being arrested for standing there
holding a sign there's like homeless
people every day holding us okay but we
bought it he didn't have an id to give
you he did have an id ma'am and that's
what i'm trying to explain to everyone
that wanted to come out and video it
y'all didn't see the initial reaction
and y'all don't know that we've dealt
with him in the past about panhandling
yeah i understand that's against the
wall but
maybe if y'all would have calmly you
know took a little bit of initiative to
be calm about it
yes and yes i did that was my second
encounter with him today the first
encounter i politely i didn't even get
out my quarter first mcdonald's on
franklin that was panhandling too did
you get him okay and when
okay and when we get out with people we
ask for their id it was as simple as
giving your id so i can issue a citation
and you can move on
he did not want to comply
yeah
well i think some more issues will be
coming up out of this after i get a hold
of a lot more you know bigger people
than you that's fine i'm sorry you had
to deal with the aggressive dog but i
think you took it out of control okay
that's completely that's your opinion
okay
yeah a lot of people all right have a
good day officer
don't say nothing
i speak today down
wait
that's
the number that they gave me this
officer brooks to contact dave
anyone at this number want to speak to
officer brooks
no
okay so i know that's a prank call i
know that's why i get started
i bet you it was some hispanic people
that came around twice
uh
hello
hello there's officer taylor against
sonia police department somebody called
in on this number to dispatch
in reference to a salt of a animal
um
i never called this number yeah when
another officer called you there was
there was laughing in a background and
um we were just trying to figure out
what was up because uh
misuse of 911 is actually a crime so
we're trying to figure out what's going
on
no i was on the phone with one of my
friends and i got a call from a
it's the officer that called because
this number called in requesting to
speak to the officer that's involved
i don't know what's happening okay all
right okay thank you
are you are you talking about like a
rehab facility
[Music]
december to track down his dog
it is cold
it's a veteran's treatment court
uh we're trying to get him help with
this pesd
and they have one in
uh
county
that
we can try and get them into if the
magistrate will let us do that
um it's up to the master what kind of
bond he has but he does have charges
pending and he has charges pending for
resisting an officer
um and the same thing that we just
encountered with him so i can't tell you
what the bond is going to be it's
completely up to the master
all right
is there any way i'm allowed to speak on
his behalf or
um
um what i can do is give him i can give
him your number and he can use the phone
out here and if he chooses to call you
it's up to him
okay
okay i appreciate that you're welcome
thank you
hello is this uh mr jim guard
yeah who is that this is sergeant wood
with the police department how you doing
hey i'm so sorry to call you at a little
after nine at night um
i just came in at seven and i wanted to
uh i got an email that um you maybe
wanted to speak to someone
yeah we we were out there early in the
process
i just want to make sure your officers
doing their own
de-escalation and see i see stuff and
what these people are encountering and
you know
um i've been doing this job a long time
and yesterday yes sir
but that's not
you know i don't tell you anything you
know you know what to deal with yes sir
hopefully they're looking into it right
now they got body camera all they're
doing they're reviewing
yes sir we're reviewing all body camera
um
the call for service um everyone voicing
their concern uh everything's being
taken into consideration
kind of appreciate it man yeah
i spent 26 years of cheryl police
department and that's the first time
i've ever had been pissed off about
something
right right i like what charlotte for
six years so i i get it i get it you
know if there's
you know that i like the whole
escalation how you speak to somebody
make sure that that homeless person was
spoken to properly when they when the
officer first encountered them yeah
definitely for sure and not pissed off
because of the 100 coffee service
no i got you yes sir and definitely and
first off i appreciate your service um i
know you said you uh you know you're a
va and you're a veteran and we
appreciate that and your time with cmpd
we appreciate that
um but i mean
you like you said it goes without being
said you know we're we're doing as far
as the admin side um as far as the
everything that took place we're taking
everything into consideration
and uh and
they just said the dog thing i thought
shoot five dogs on swat yeah
because they're attacking pit bulls
right right right
that's i don't understand that part
either so
yeah for sure
yes sir we're uh we're
we're
we're crossing all of our t's and
dotting off our eyes and you know no
stone's gonna be left unturned
thank you i appreciate it yeah
good night now yes sir thank you all
right bye-bye
mr guard
at seven 704-608-9504